it's not your sleek steering last
skyscraper when you stand on the
building in the corner and look up you
almost see a tree
when the client came to us for for a
hotel downtown it was a great
opportunity to see whether we could
rethink the tropical high-rise as being
one that is actually very porous once we
created this porous building blocks
within it we wanted to wrap this with a
mesh that will allow us to have a living
facade when we created this living
facade the ideas was very simple we have
created a lot of horizontal sky gardens
before where birds and insects could fly
and land on the green habitats but we
haven't quite realized living habitat
for animals who would climb and when we
created this vertical connector for all
this horizontal green habitats we
realized a squirrel could actually hop
from a tree onto the building and climb
onto the the topmost floor of this
building and this is something that
intrigued us and we realized that if we
actually connect neighboring buildings
with such amenities we would actually
create a very vibrant ecosystem for not
just humans but also for animals and I
think this is something that would
transform how we think cities it doesn't
need to be concrete and jungle anymore
it can be one that we actually live in
harmony with nature and this was at the
end of the day they aim for us